mes chers collègues la séance s'est
reprises l'ordre du jour appelle les
votes solennelle sur le projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de la Justice pour les années
2023 2027 et le projet de loi organique
relative à l'ouverture la modernisation
et la responsabilité du corps judiciaire
je vous rappelle que la Conférence des
Présidents a décidé que ces deux votes
seraient précédentes d'explications de
votre commune
donc explication de votre 5 minutes par
orateur le premier sera Jean-Félix
Aquaviva pour le groupe Yot
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
durant l'examen de ces deux textes
justice nous avons tous partagé le même
constat le système judiciaire de ce pays
a besoin d'un gros coup de pouce si
j'ose m'exprimer familièrement et c'est
peu dire la hausse du budget de jute de
justice que vous proposez de 9,6 à 10,7
milliards d'euros sur la période 2023
2027 et clairement indispensable tout
comme l'augmentation des effectifs cela
reste limité sur la compare avec celle
de l'Intérieur notamment nous avons déjà
explicité sur le contenu des textes en
eux-mêmes notre groupe réaffirme
clairement ce n'est pas une surprise son
opposition l'article 3 qui entend
autorisé l'activation à distance des
appareils électroniques à l'issue du
propriétaire au fin de géolocalisation
et de captation d'images et de son
cette mesure nous fait franchir un
nouveau cap dangereux et nous rejoignons
la réserve du Conseil d'État qui
souligne une atteinte importante au
droit à la vie privée en commission et
en séance plusieurs garanties ont été
apportées notamment pour assurer le
respect du secret des échanges entre la
personne espionnée son conseil mais là
encore ses avancées restent limitées
nous regrettons le choix final du
gouvernement de généraliser cette
technique d'enquête pour la
géolocalisation à tous les délits et
crime contre les personnes punies de
moins de 50 prisons le choix du Sénat de
borner cette technique au crime puni
d'au moins de 10 ans de prison était
malgré tout pour nous plus proportionner
il en va de même pour l'extension de
recours aux perquisitions de nuit dont
l'encadrement prévu ne suffit pas notre
sens
nous restons dubitatifs par ailleurs sur
le choix de prier privé le juge de
liberté de la détention de ces fonctions
civiles qui concernent essentiellement
le contentieux des étrangers
selon nous le renforcement des équipes
des JLD était préférable pour permettre
de tenir des délais raisonnables
sur la partie territoriale à présent
vous avez affiché monsieur le garde des
sceaux la volonté de dédier des mesures
au territoire exposés à des difficultés
d'attractivité certaines juridictions
des zones rurales et surtout d'outre-mer
et de Corse souffre d'un manque de
personnel
la création d'un dispositif
contractuelle de priorité d'affectation
en contrepartie pour les magistrats qui
ont accepté une nomination dans ces
territoires peu attractifs va dans le
bon sens il s'agit d'une logique
incitative que notre groupe soutient
d'où notre satisfaction à la suite du
rétablissement de l'article 5 du projet
de loi organique renforçant ainsi les
dispositifs de délégation pour les rues
juridiction d'outre-mer et de Corse
nous sommes également satisfaits de
l'adoption de plusieurs de nos amendes
en séance en faveur de juridictions
corses et ultramarines comme toujours
avec les textes programmation ces
engagements sont inscrits dans le
rapport annexé qui n'a pas nous le
savons tous de valeur contraignantes ce
dispositif limité à trois mois est très
probablement utilisé essentiellement en
visioconférence ne peut remplacer
évidemment des dominations du magistrat
au sein juridictions corses et à plein
temps en donnant notamment une place
plus importante ce que nous souhaitons
au juge originaire du territoire
concernés pour toutes ces raisons le
groupe lot s'abiendra majoritairement je
vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le député pour
le groupe Renaissance la parole est à
Madame Caroline Abadie
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
gardeesseau monsieur le président de la
commission des lois messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues la
justice est au cœur de toutes les
préoccupations ces dernières semaines
que ce soit au sein de sa assemblée ou
en dehors je pense bien sûr aux émeutes
qui ont suivi la mort du jeune à elle
ces événements troublants parfois
choquants nous rappelle le rôle
fondamental de notre système judiciaire
dans la préservation de l'ordre public
de la paix sociale et de la cohésion
nationale la justice c'est l'épine
dorsale de notre démocratie elle
constitue le pilier central sur lequel
repose notre société pour qu'elle puisse
remplir pleinement sa mission et faire
face aux défis profond mise en lumière
par les États généraux de la justice
nous lui accordons des moyens
historiques en effet la programmation
ambitieuse que nous allons voter
aujourd'hui portera le budget de le
ministère de la Justice à hauteur de 11
milliards d'euros en 2027 soit une
hausse de 60% en disant c'est
considérable c'est massif c'est
historique
cette loi entérinera le recrutement de
10000 emplois supplémentaires dont 1500
greffiers près de 1700 attachés de
justice ou encore des surveillants
pénitentiaires ou autres conseillers de
probation et bien sûr 1500 magistrats
plus que le nombre recruté ces dernières
20 années
de la même manière cet effort budgétaire
participe à la revalorisation des
rémunérations des métiers de la justice
je pense particulièrement au greffier
avec qui la Chancellerie à trouver un
accord de méthodes relatif à la
revalorisation de leur profession je
pense aussi aux magistrats dont le
statut va évoluer grâce aux nouvelles
dispositions prévues par le projet de
loi organique en particulier l'ouverture
et la simplification des voies d'accès
de la magistrature en vue d'attirer plus
de candidats mais aussi de moderniser
leur carrière conformément à leurs
attentes sur cette partie je tiens à
saluer le travail important de monsieur
le rapporteur Didier Paris je pense
aussi au directeur de service de
probation envers qui la Chancellerie va
mener une réflexion de revalorisation de
leur métier grâce à un amendement porté
par le groupe Renaissance visant à
corriger un effet de bord créé par la
revalorisation récente des conseillers
de probation
face aux autres défis majeurs auxquels
notre société confrontée ces projets de
loi apportent également des réponses
concrètes pour renforcer la protection
des victimes d'infraction notamment des
mineurs grâce à un amendement
Renaissance porté par Sarah tanzili
expérimenté des tribunaux d'activités
économiques pour mère-derniser la
justice économique créer des pôles
spécialisés en violence intrafamiliale
dans nos juridictions sur la base du
très bon rapport de Madame Emilie
Chandler faciliter la mise en oeuvre de
la compétence universelle sur les
propositions de Guillaume Gouffier
Valente afin de faciliter pour nos
tribunaux la poursuite des auteurs
contre de crimes contre l'humanité et de
crime de guerre lutter contre la
criminalité organisée le terrorisme avec
des techniques d'enquête renforcées
développer la médiation matière civile
rénover nos tribunaux via 60 projets
d'agrandissement et de rénovation
énergétique sur nos territoires pour
suivre l'objectif 0 papier à l'horizon
2027 je ne suis pas exhaustif mais déjà
rien que pendant ces deux semaines
d'examen tout en tout comme en
commission nous avons aussi pu parler de
la situation carcérale qui préoccupe
tous les bancs de cette assemblée en
effet quand nous sommes sortis des
débats caricaturaux nous avons tous
admis que la surpopulation carcérale ne
permet pas une détention digne et prive
de chances de réinsertion pour moi c'est
la clé de voûte de la lutte contre la
récidive nous n'avons donc pas fini de
parler de régulation carcérale même si
dans ce texte aujourd'hui rien n'a été
ajouté sur ce sujet dans cette optique
nous poursuivons la construction du plan
15000 places lancées en 2018 c'est un
certain sur les bancs des républicains
pensent qu'il faut 3000 places de plus
encore faudra-t-il achever ce plan 15000
sans encombre urbanistique
sans encombre urbanistique c'est bien le
sous amendement qui a déposé le groupe
renaissance pour leur et dans l'urgence
pour lutter contre la surpopulation nous
préférons rendre la peine de travail
d'intérêt général plus effective et
encore faciliter le recours à
l'assignation à résidence avec
surveillance électronique le groupe
Renaissance par ses amendements a
contribué à ces mêmes objectifs en
proposant un délai de convocation
raccourci chez le SPIP ou encore l'avis
du SPIP dans la décision de
renouvellement de la détention
provisoire je tiens au groupe au nom du
groupe Renaissance remercier toutes les
parties prenantes qui ont donné à ce
texte toute son importance à commencer
par Monsieur le gardeesseau dans
l'engagement sans faille a permis de
décrocher des budgets historiques à mes
yeux les rapporteurs Balanant terre liés
Pradal et j'avais déjà remercié monsieur
Paris qui ont grandement contribué à
l'amélioration de ces projets de loi
quand on est attaché à l'institution
judiciaire quand on est attaché à lui
donner des moyens on ne peut que voter
pour ce texte c'est ce que fera le
groupe Renaissance en responsabilité et
avec fierté je vous remercie ma chère
collègue la parole est à Madame Pascal
borde pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur le président de la
commission des lois messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues depuis 40
ans aucun gouvernement n'a fait quoi que
ce soit pour préserver cette justice qui
est la nôtre nous l'avons laissé ce
déliter d'année en année jusqu'à ce
qu'elle soit dans un état de délabrement
tel que la France se situe bien loin
dans le classement des pays européens
qui investissent le moins dans leur
justice vous avez dit monsieur le garde
des sceaux sujets des textes que nous
examinons que c'était le projet de loi
le plus ambitieux et celui qui donnait
le plus de budget à la justice depuis 30
ans cette année un peu vite certes
l'effort est louable minou partons de si
loin que comparaison n'est pas raison et
l'effort devra être poursuivi sinon nous
nous rattraperons jamais notre
incommensurable retard sur nos voisins
européens précisément s'agissant de la
promesse de création de 10000 15000 voir
infinies 18 nouvelle place de prison il
m'apparaît que votre enthousiasme mérite
d'être sérieusement tempéré car nombre
de ces places de prison ne verront
manifestement pas le jour dans les
délais indiqués dans la mesure où si
certains réclament haut et fort face
caméra des places de prison d'autres de
la même appartenance politique multiplie
les tentatives d'entraves en refusant
notamment les autorisations d'urbanisme
nécessaires savoir mettre de côté ce
petit jeu politique ne nuirez pas à
l'intérêt de la nation l'article 2
prévoit la réécriture à droit constant
du code de procédure pénale certains à
gauche affirment que le travail de
réécriture devrait être fait par les
parlementaires et qu'il ne faut donc pas
donner au gouvernement l'habilitation
qu'il sollicite certes mais c'est
oublier qu'il s'agit là d'un travail de
bénédictin qui par ailleurs demande des
connaissances très approfondies en droit
pénal et en procédure pénale afin de
donner une meilleure lisibilité à ce
code
devenu au fil des ans totalement
illisibles et indigeste et ce n'est pas
faire un jus au parlementaire que nous
sommes que de dire qu'il ne me semble
pas réaliste que ce soit nous qui
devions nous atteler à cette tâche nous
n'en avons ni le temps ni les
compétences il serait donc irresponsable
de ne pas voter cette habilitation tant
la réforme du CPP est attendue par
l'ensemble des acteurs du monde
judiciaire en revanche nous serons des
parlementaires plus vigilants encore car
la coutumée car ce n'est pas monsieur le
ministre un blanc sain que nous vous
donnons via la méditation que vous nous
demandez l'article 3 comprend un certain
nombre de mesures parmi lesquelles d'une
part la possibilité de perquisition de
visite de mixilière et de saisie de
pièces à conviction de nuit et d'autre
part l'activation à distance de
l'appareil électronique au fin de
géolocalisation pour les délits puni
d'au moins 5 ans d'emprisonnement nos
amendements ont permis de revenir au
texte initial de 5 ans et non pas 10 ans
et de permettre aussi l'application de
ce dispositif pour nombre de faits
relevant de la criminalité organisée
notamment en matière de trafic de
suppléant qui si le plancher de 10 ans
avait été maintenu aurait été échappé à
ce dispositif bienvenu j'entends
certains s'élever contre cette
possibilité attentatoire selon eux la
vie privée néanmoins si l'on veut
réellement lutter contre la criminalité
organisée alors il faut se donner les
moyens de le faire et doter les
enquêteurs des mêmes moyens que ceux
utilisés par ces groupes criminels à ce
sujet
l'orbecueo procureur de la République de
Paris affirmait très récemment la lutte
contre la haute criminalité organisée
est un défi actuel un défi majeur
aujourd'hui le niveau de la menace
est-elle que l'on détecte des risques de
déstabilisation de notre État de droit
de notre modèle économique mais
également de nos entreprises à un niveau
stratégique majeur si les organisations
que l'on affronte nos aucune limite dans
leurs moyens financiers aucune limite
dans leur frontières ni dans leur champ
d'action la situation qui est donc grave
et si l'on ne veut pas que notre pays
devienne narco-état il nous faut vite
réagir réagir pardon vite et fort c'est
en partie la raison pour laquelle je
déplore le fait que ce projet de loi
conjugue à l'infini les mesures
alternatives à la prison une mesure
alternative pour un délinquant primaire
soit pas pour un délinquant chevronné ce
n'est pas parce que nous n'avons pas
suffisamment de place de prison qu'il
faut systématiquement recourir à une
mesure alternative alors où à l'heure ou
en matière de criminalité organisée des
défis majeurs nous attendent proposés à
troupe pris une peine alternative me
semble relever d'une décorrélation
totale avec le monde réel
enfin ce projet de loi rappelle une fois
encore que la victime est toujours la
grande oubliée du procès pénal en effet
dans ce projet de loi la place réservée
aux victimes nos cumant tout et pour
tout que deux pages et demi sur 121
pages dire que ses potes euphémisme pour
conclure nous voterons ces textes car
même si nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
certaines mesures proposées le budget
qui sera voté permettra de mener en
partie la politique pénale que nous
voulons
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame André torignat
pour le groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre Président Monsieur les
rapporteurs vous êtes contre tout vous
ne voulez pas débattre voilà ce que nous
ont dit Monsieur le Ministre et les
rapporteurs un club d'homme refusant la
parité soit dit en passant
des propositions nous en avons à une
exception près vous les avez toutes
balayées d'un avis défavorable le plus
souvent sans explication ni argument les
qualifiants je vous cite deux bêtises et
d'inertie c'est dire le sens que vous
avez du débat contradictoire
63 avis défavorables qui montrent que
vous êtes contre tout oui vous êtes
contre
le service public de la justice vous
êtes contre des emplois pérennes vous
êtes vous inscrivez dans la loi la
flexibilité chez les magistrats pour
combler les manques affectation
provisoire hors de leur juridiction
intégration provisoire à temps partiel
recours au magistrat honoraires
idem pour le pénitentiaire vous êtes
contre de vrais augmentations
substantielles de ces métiers peut
attractifs contre la titularisation des
CDI existants vous préférez embaucher
des contractuels vous allez même jusqu'à
ouvrir la réserve pénitentiaire à 67 ans
pour les surveillants quelle provocation
d'après la réforme des retraites
contre le principe de la gratuité du
service public de la justice vous
instaurez une contribution pour les
saisies des tribunaux d'activités
économiques certes cela ne touchera pas
les entreprises de moins de 250 salariés
mais vous avez fait entrer le verre dans
le fruit contre un système pérenne de
régulation carcérale vous n'avez écouté
ni les préconisations de la Contrôleur
général des lieux de privation de
liberté ni le rappeur sauvé le ministre
renie l'avocat du pont Moretti qui
écrivait ainsi en 2020 au président
Macron réduire la population tarcérale
n'est ni dangereux ni déraisonnable vous
avez préféré rajouter à vos 15000 places
de prison les 3000 que réclamés monsieur
cioti monsieur Houlier est allé encore
plus loin en disant chiche ORL qui en
demandait 10000 de plus la droite et
l'extrême droite sont ainsi rassurés par
l'équipe macronienne contre toutes les
associations des défenseurs de liberté
dont la LDH c'est vrai déjà attaquer
quelques semaines auparavant par
Monsieur Darmanin
liberté sur l'article 3 florilège de
mesure contre nos libertés fondamentales
surveillance généralisée avec la
possibilité d'enregistrer son et image
de tout individu suspect d'une peine de
5 ans et non plus de 10 comme l'avait
voté le Sénat
élargissement des perquisitions de nuit
pour les terroristes dites-vous mais
comme c'est votre collègue de
l'Intérieur qui desserne ce label les
prétendus et con terroristes n'ont qu'à
bien se tenir
contre le Conseil National des Barreaux
dont vous avez déformé sans scrupules et
à votre avantage la préconisation qui
s'opposait au principe de
confidentialité des juristes
d'entreprises votre argument parce que
c'est dans l'air du temps les gang
privilage dans le texte preuve que vous
êtes aussi contre la défense de la
langue de Molière
vous étiez contre une justice au service
des plus modestes en voulant des
judiciariser les saisies sur
rémunération mais là malgré votre avis
défavorable notre amendement a été voté
vous êtes contre la mention voter à
l'unanimité par l'Association européenne
des magistrats que nous avons relayé qui
alerté sur les mesures disciplinaires de
l'article 8 du texte organique en cela
vous vous montrez bien peu défenseur des
séparations des pouvoirs sans doute
est-ce dans votre intérêt sur ce sujet
le rapporteur Paris a même été contre
une proposition qu'il valait pourtant en
2020 quand il était alors rapporteur de
la commission dans quatre présidé par
mon collègue bernalisme j'avais alerté
au début de l'examen de ce texte sans
écoute sans débat on ne retiendrait de
ce budget soit disant historique qu'il
ne représente que la moitié de celui de
la police c'est donc fait les 25 heures
de séances auront aussi permis de voir
les accointances entre la macronie et
l'extrême droite puisque la minorité
présidentielle a voté contre avec le
groupe RN à 45%. cette réforme s'inscrit
dans une logique néolibérale et même
algérienne du service public dont on
mesure les conséquences délétères allez
ok à l'école et à l'hôpital nous
voterons parce que nous sommes aussi
votre temps est écoulé donne-nous
je vous remercie
et merci de respecter votre temps de
parole la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Gosselin pour le groupe les républicain
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues après trois semaines de
travaux une semaine en commission des
lois deux en hémicycle nous arrivons
donc au terme de l'examen de ces textes
justice présenté par le gouvernement
globalement vous le savez il se
présentait comme la mise en forme en
proposition du rapport sauvé
issu des états généraux de 2022
sauveront-ils la justice de la
clochardisation nous verrons mais en
tout cas nous allons essayer d'apporter
un certain nombre de réponses deux
textes disaient un texte de loi
organique qui n'appelle pas
d'observation insurmontable ou
particulières de notre côté ils
prévoient ça a été dit la refonte des
voies d'accès à la magistrature un
certain nombre d'éléments pour les
magistrats et concernant leur statuts
ils modifie le mode de soutien le mode
de scrutin pardon du Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature je vous le dis tout
de suite nous voterons ce texte et sans
aucune difficulté un peu plus d'éléments
si vous le voulez bien sur le projet de
loi ordinaire qui mérite une attention
beaucoup plus long il s'habille il
s'agit bien d'une loi de programmation
de financement qui certes fixe une
trajectoire pour la justice et qui
passerait avec un budget intéressant de
9 milliards et demi environ après de 11
milliards en 2027 mais pour autant pour
autant ce n'est pas un texte qui doit
faire l'écart avec la politique pénale
que nous attendons je le redis très très
clairement les républicains attendent
une politique pénale ferme exemplaire et
rapide et dans la continuité des émeutes
et des violences urbaines de ces
dernières semaines il n’est pas question
de flancher nous ne cautionnerons jamais
une forme de désarmement pénal qui a été
initié par Christiane Taubira et souvent
poursuivi il faut le dire par Madame
beloubet nous vous avons entendu
monsieur le ministre avec des mots sur
la rapidité la fermeté le systématisme
et bien nous vous prenons au mot et
comme nous l'avons déjà dit dans
plusieurs interventions pendant les
débats parlementaires chiches nous
serons là au rendez-vous pour rappeler
la politique pénale ferme que nous
attendons nous allons pas non plus
transiger transiser pardon sur la
question carcérale cela reviendrait à
passer sous silence là la réalité de
l'exécution des peines de prison en
France et cela reviendrait aussi d'une
certaine façon à offenser les victimes
oui aujourd'hui il y a des risques de
surpopulation carcérale même une réalité
de la population carcérale qui est en
augmentation mais nous n'arrivons pas à
loger tous les détenus et on voit bien
comment certains ajustements sont faits
parfois par un certain nombre de
magistrats alors bien sûr il y a un plan
prison le plan 15000 qui avait été
annoncé en 2018 mais l'exécution de ce
plan a pris aussi du retard et nous
voulons absolument qu'il y ait un coup
de collier sur ces 15000 places mais
nous actons et nous nous réjouissons
contrairement peut-être à ce que pense
notre collègue Abadie d'avoir fait
inscrire dans l'article premier un plan
avec les 80 000 places de prison
c'est-à-dire un plan 15000 + 3000 places
de prison qui sont nécessaires aux
besoins d'aujourd'hui et qui permettront
aussi il n'y a pas que le côté répressif
et qui permettront aussi de remplir le
contrat de lancer l'humain individuel
qui est une vieille baderne qui date de
1875 seulement et qui est repoussé
d'année en année donc nous oui nous nous
accrochons à cette victoire des 3000
places de prison qui ne nous paraissent
pas secondaire chers collègues c'est un
engagement qui a été pris devant la
représentation nationale et nous serons
au rendez-vous dans les territoires dans
les collectivités pour accélérer la mise
à disposition des terrains comme il se
doit nous n'aurons pas un double
discours je tiens à le dire nous allons
aussi nous réjouir de voir un certain
nombre d'avancées dans ce texte comme le
légal privilège pour les juristes
d'entreprise ce qui nous permettra de
lutter l'arme armée égale avec leur
collègue anglo-saxons nous nous
réjouissons aussi d'avoir pu faire
écarter la contribution pour la justice
économique des petites et moyennes
entreprises puisque cela a été dit tout
à l'heure celle de moins de 255 salariés
n'auront pas à supporter cette
contribution alors en résumé conclusion
nous rappelons une politique pénale
ferme et nous l'appelons de nos vœux et
sans mollir nous rappelons aussi la
nécessité d'une politique carcérale
importante avec des places de prison que
nous avons obtenus ce sont par ailleurs
des moyens supplémentaires pour la
justice on ne va pas écarter d'un revers
de main dix mille emplois 1500 postes de
magistrats autant de greffiers des
personnels dans l'esprits qui sont
nécessaires des surveillants tout cela
nous amène en responsabilité avec
vigilance attention et évidemment un
soutien critique mais un soutien réel à
propos er un vote majoritaire pour ce
texte car il semble aller dans le bon
sens mais nous n'excluons pas d'être
présent monsieur le ministre
naturellement à chaque rendez-vous
budgétaire et à chaque loi de finance
pour être vigilant au moment de
l'exécution et des programmes et des
budgets je vous remercie beaucoup mon
cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur emmanuellement
don pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente je garde des
sceaux monsieur le président de la
commission des lois messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues au début de
ce long parcours législatif j'avais tenu
à rappeler avec ma collègue ma collègue
Blandine brocard quelques principes
principes et marqueurs essentiels des
conceptions que notre groupe se fait de
la réforme judiciaire
reprenons-les en conclusion de notre
débat en premier lieu il faut une
justice plus rapide
et plus efficace nous partageons sur ce
point l'objectif premier des deux textes
en second lieu il faut donner au
magistrat les moyens de remplir leur
mission
certes ils seront plus nombreux cela a
été dit mais il faut veiller à leur
niveau de formation et leurs qualités
professionnelles
nous nous sommes efforcés avec ma
collègue Laurence virginiewski de
conforter ses orientations nous
resterons bien entendu vigilants à ce
sujet par ailleurs la consécration par
la loi d'une équipe autour d'eux et la
stabilisation des personnels
contractuelles sont des avancées
positives et nous souhaitons que le rôle
essentiel des greffiers dans le
fonctionnement de l'institution
judiciaire soit confirmée
en troisième lieu il faut moderniser la
procédure pénale elle doit être plus
accessible et plus simple la
reconndification à droit constant
proposer est impérative
les parlementaires doivent être associés
à ce travail les garanties ont été
obtenues et nous en prenons volontiers
actes monsieur le ministre la procédure
pénale doit ensuite s'adapter à
l'évolution des comportements
délictueux nous avons souhaité que ces
adaptations assurent le délicat
équilibre
entre le maintien de l'ordre public et
le respect des libertés fondamentales
Erwan Balanant le rapporteur sur cette
partie du texte il y avait eu et nous
saluons également les efforts portés en
particulier par notre collègue projet
pour redéfinir
la criminalité routière qui vient de
trouver d'ailleurs sa traduction sa
traduction pardon dans les annonces de
la première ministre hier en quatrième
lieu il faut comporter conforter la
politique pénitentiaire et notre groupe
a obtenu je crois des avancées très
positives à ce sujet en particulier avec
la mise en œuvre effective des travaux
d'intérêt général une attention plus
importante à la réinsertion sociale des
détenus
et la mise en place d'une aide
psychologique au personnel pénitentiaire
pour autant le débat reste ouvert nous
attendons d'ailleurs avec intérêt les
conclusions demain en commission des
lois de la mission d'information sur la
régulation carcérale de nos collègues
Abadie et faux sillons néanmoins rien ne
sera possible sans un accroissement
significatif du nombre de places de
prison et la résorption des prisons
vétustes souvenons-nous qu'une prison ce
n'est pas que des bâtiments des détenus
et des personnels
la prison marque son empreinte au-delà
de ces murs c'est pourquoi notre groupe
a soutenu l'inscription dans le rapport
annexé de l'objectif de 3000 places
supplémentaires au-delà des chiffres
l'exemple désolant de la maison d'arrêt
de la Talaudière dans ma circonscription
montre à quel point l'État devra se
surpasser pour réaliser ce programme en
cinquième lieu il nous faut décharger le
contentieux ordinaire par la voie
judiciaire en imposant une véritable
révolution de l'amiable
l'adoption de notre amendement créant un
magistrat référent
du recours amiable au sein de chaque dur
juridiction va dans ce sens en sixième
lieu il faut répondre aux agressions qui
minent notre société par un traitement
attentif et dédié aux violences
intrafamilales en particulier et
l'adoption de notre amendement prévoyant
des assistances spécialisés vif dans les
futurs pôles concourt à cet objectif en
septième lieu il faut expérimenter pour
simplifier et adapter la justice
commerciale au monde économique
d'aujourd'hui la création des tribunaux
des affaires économiques et la bienvenue
comme et bienvenue l'exonération de la
contribution pour la justice économique
en faveur des petites entreprises dont
j'avais pris l'initiative en huitième
mieux il faut faire du recours numérique
une réussite car c'est poursuivre
résolument la modernisation des
juridictions tout en facilitant leur
accès à tous ceux qui ont à faire ou
font la justice et je pense notamment
aux avocats surtout ces sujets de
nombreux autres le rapport annexé a été
l'occasion d'un vaste et riche débat
traduit par l'adoption de très
nombreuses amendements il nous reste à
espérer tous ensemble que ces bonnes
intentions se réalisent avec une force
égale dans les faits vous pouvez compter
monsieur le garder saut sur le groupe
démocrate pour y prendre toute sa part
de manière résolue consciente la demande
sociale de justice n'a jamais été aussi
forte qu'aujourd'hui c'est pour toutes
ces raisons que notre groupe votera les
deux projets de loi je vous remercie je
vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à madame Cécile intermeyer
pour le groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues nous achevons ce jour
deux semaines de débat le long examen du
rapport annexé traduit le besoin de
revoir le coup près des articles 40 et
45 l'âme de dissuasion du débat
parlementaire et l'intérêt que nous
devons porter à une annexe sans porter
normative nous avons tous conscience de
l'état de délabrement du système
judiciaire français de la souffrance de
ses professionnels dont le métier digne
est exigeant perd de son sens au regard
des difficultés tant matérielles que
judiciaires qui détourne le justicier de
cette institution je remercie les
rapporteurs Jean Tellier rapporteur
général
Erwan Balan Philippe Pradal de leur aide
à trouver parfois des compromis avec le
gouvernement cela était particulièrement
vrai sur les questions statutaires et
déontologiques du projet de loi
organique avec Didier Paris
ces textes doivent porter l'espérance
d'une réforme systémique de
l'institution judiciaire telle que la
exprimé Jean-Marc Sauvet président des
États généraux par une programmation
budgétaire indispensable avec 2
milliards supplémentaires d'ici 2027 et
la création de 10000 emplois dont 1500
magistrats et 1500 gifiés certains
d'entre nous n'y croient pas pour ma
part je considère que cette
programmation sera vérifiée par nos
soins chaque année dans le cadre de la
loi de finances d'ailleurs à cette fin
nous avons obtenu par voie d'amendements
qu'au 30 avril de chaque année en
rapport soit remis au Parlement sur les
créations d'emplois et la consommation
des crédits nous
vérifierons aussi l'efficacité de la
nouvelle politique numérique deuxième
point sombre du système judiciaire
français
par des modalités de travail
profondément modifiées nous devons là
aussi engager une réforme systémique
elles devront désormais s'appuyer ses
équipes sur une véritable pardon équipe
autour du magistrat associant au premier
chef les attachés de justice et nous le
demandons avec un assistance les
greffiers l'ouverture de la magistrature
à d'autres professionnels des
connaisseurs du droit devraient
permettre nous l'espérons l'augmentation
attendue du nombre de magistrats et la
peur de leur propre culture dans cette
profession le projet de loi organique
dispose de mesures fortes en ce sens par
la simplification du droit cela a été
dit enfin s'il a justice est assise sur
le socle constitutionnel de son
indépendance il est essentiel pour notre
démocratie du veillée gardons en mémoire
l'exemple de la Pologne et de la Hongrie
pour autant l'indépendance ne signifie
pas l'indifférence la responsabilité
renforcée des magistrats devant le CSM
la réaffirmation de leur liberté
syndicale et l'inscription dans la loi
des conseils de juridiction avec la
participation de l'ensemble des
parlementaires du ressort participent de
cette exigence le rôle local du député
c'est aussi de connaître les faits sur
le terrain des lois qu'il a voté mais
c'est une réforme systémique qui trouve
ici ses limites avec la question de la
surpopulation carcérale monsieur le
ministre le discours démagogique du tout
enfermement a trouvé plus d'écho dans le
gouvernement que notre proposition très
partagée n'est-ce pas Madame madame
mesdames les députés à gauche et au
centre de l'hémicides d'une avancée vers
une régulation carcérale efficace tant
pour la dignité des détenus que pour
lutter contre la récidive je passe sur
l'épisode pitoyable et ridicule d'une
annonce surprise de 3000 places de
prison supplémentaires dans un rapport
annexé heureusement sans valeur
contraignante
alors ces limites aussi on les trouve
avec l'incohérence de supprimer le juge
du cœur des litiges au travers de deux
mesures celles relatives aux saisies sur
rumines rémunération forte heureusement
supprimée à ce stade par votre par votre
majoritaire en séance publique ou celle
étant dans le champ de compétences des
tribunaux des activités économiques sans
pour autant prévoir la présence d'un
juge assesseur professionnel extension à
un secteur agricole qui plus est très
satisfait du travail des magistrats du
tribunal judiciaire
enfin les nouvelles techniques spéciales
d'enquête se disent ce dispositif fait
peur et je pense que le dispositif
actuel est suffisant et ce que veulent
les procureurs c'est d'abord de pouvoir
mobiliser les services d'enquête
judiciaire ce que ne leur permet plus la
réforme engagée par la loi de
programmation budgétaire du ministère de
l'Intérieur enfin nous regrettons
l'absence d'approche globale sur la
médiation et la justice restera-t-il le
texte ne parle pas non plus de des
juridictions sociales et des prud'hommes
et pourtant les délais de plus de 5 ans
voire 10 ans en appel appel de notre
part une action en conclusion nous
partageons tous le souci de répondre à
l'attente des personnels de juridiction
comme des justiciables
je reconnais l'effort financier nous
avons un engagement de par la loi de
programmation et parce que la réforme
systématique systémique nous semble
aller dans le bon sens nous serons donc
une petite majorité de députés de notre
groupe à nous abstenir d'autres au
regard des dispositions de l'article 3
qu'il redoute liberticide et des
réserves évoquées plus hauts voteront
contre le texte de loi ordinaire en
revanche l'ensemble du groupe votera
pour le texte organique je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame naï mammoutchou
pour le groupe horizon
je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
garde des sceaux messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues la
justice n'est pas n'importe quel service
public elle est la richesse en
particulier de ceux qui n'en ont pas
pour retrouver de l'ordre de l'équilibre
et du lien social
elle est l'ultime recours quand tous les
autres services publics ont échoué la
justice en cela et la première dette de
la souveraineté comme disait Portalis et
notre responsabilité puisque nous
participons dans nos fonctions à
l'exercice de cette souveraineté c'est
de tout faire pour honorer cette tête
l'actualité a montré combien la justice
était essentielle et devait être défendu
pour que fonctionne un État fort
impartial et qui inspire le respect ceux
qui discréditent la justice qui la
remette en cause en cautionnant la
violation des règles en violant parfois
eux-mêmes les règles cela ont légitimé
l'usage de la force et de la violence
ils l'ont encore fait récemment en
érigeant les émeutiers en victimes et en
désignant coupable les policiers
les juges ou les élus je les mets en
garde on ne construit pas un projet sur
des ruines ce n'est pas pour rien que la
justice est un pilier de notre
démocratie et que nous devons tout faire
pour qu'elles tiennent debout et solides
les textes que nous nous apprêtons à
voter sont une nouvelle occasion de la
renforcer
la justice a longtemps été le parent
pauvre des lois de finances nous
tournons définitivement cette page du
sous-investissement avec 11 milliards
d'euros de budget pour 2027 c'est-à-dire
parce que c'est important de rappeler le
cadre de référence plus 60% de crédit
pour le ministère de la Justice depuis
2017 je veux saluer l'ambition
budgétaire sans précédent porté par le
garde des sceaux qui est allé obtenir
ses crédits pour que la justice se
répare pour permettre à nos agents
d'être revalorisés pour réhabiliter
tribunaux et prison pour étoffer les
équipes de magistrats
mais ce n'est pas tout à côté de la
question des moyens la justice continue
d'être réformée pour mieux fonctionner
je suis spinale juste ici
économique le groupe Horizon a défendu
un certain nombre de positions et nous
avons obtenu l'amende l'adoption
d'amendement important sur les
techniques de déclenchement à distance
des appareils électroniques
il est indispensable indispensable à nos
yeux et même évident de donner aux
enquêteurs les moyens d'enquêter
efficacement la réalité que ne veulent
pas voir certains c'est celle d'une
criminalité astucieuse qui emploie des
moyens de plus en plus sophistiqués pour
violer la loi mais parce que ces
techniques sont particulièrement
intrusives nous avons proposé de les
encadrer de les subordonner à la nature
et à la gravité des faits à une durée
d'autorisation strictement proportionnée
à l'objectif recherché et en prenant
soin d'exclure les professions qui sont
dépositaires d'un secret qui doit être
protégé avocat magistrat journaliste
parlementaire et médecin avec mon groupe
nous avons également porté le projet de
la justice restaurative sur lequel nous
sommes très impliqués et avec d'autres
convaincus que parallèlement à la
justice contentieuse il y a la place
dans un certain nombre de cas pour un
espace de dialogue sécurisé qui permette
à l'auteur de se responsabiliser et à la
victime de se reconstruire
nous avons également fait voter
l'exclusion des associations des
fondations des fonds de dotation de
l'expérimentation du Tribunal des
affaires économiques ainsi que la
représentation des agriculteurs au sein
de ce même tribunal et nous serons
vigilants en commission mixte paritaire
à conserver ses équilibres un mot sur le
sujet de la régulation carcérale comme
solution à la surpopulation dans les
prisons nous y sommes opposés ce n'est
pas notre choix politique nous disons
que ce n'est pas faire justice de ne pas
incarcérer quand il y a lieu d'incarrer
ou de faire sortir ceux qui n'ont pas
perdu l'intégralité de leur peine du
seul fait de la surpopulation conscient
des difficultés de l'administration
pénitentiaire bien sûr nous soutenons la
construction de nouvelles places de
prison
et la poursuite de nos travaux sur les
alternatives à la détention sur les
aménagements de peine pour éviter les
sorties sèches sur les dispositifs de
réinsertion d'accompagnement pour lutter
évidemment contre la récidive enfin la
réforme statutaire de la magistrature
est une envers une avancée majeure la
diversification des profils les
garanties nouvelles qui sont apportées
de protection de responsabilité
d'indépendance du corps de la
magistrature sont une nouvelle grille de
lecture moderne du métier de juge mes
chers collègues ces réformes ont
l'ambition de redonner à l'institution
judiciaire de véritables moyens d'agir
une justice efficace rapide accessible
qui rétablissent un peu plus le lien et
la confiance de nos concitoyens c'est le
visage de la justice de demain que nous
appelons de nos vœux le groupe horizon
votera ces deux projets de loi je vous
remercie ma chère collègues je vous
indique
que je fais annoncer le scrutin dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale nous
avons encore deux orateurs monsieur
jérémyordanov pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
gardeesseurs collègues la justice est
une institution clé de notre République
et nous avons conscience de l'Intérieur
nécessité de la fortifier mais vos
textes ne sont pas satisfaisants
nous nous abstiendrons sur la loi
organique qui comporte des points sur
lesquels nous ne sommes pas en désaccord
par exemple la diversification des voies
de recrutement pour faire face à
l'urgence mais qui comporte aussi des
points problématiques
l'indépendance de la justice aurait dû
être un ex-fort de cette réforme nous
assistons plutôt à un mouvement inverse
je pense en particulier à la
transmission d'office aux garde des
sceaux des plaintes pourtant juger
irrecevable à l'encontre des magistrats
sur la loi de programmation nous aurions
aimé pouvoir voter l'augmentation du
budget nous aurions aimé néanmoins sans
avoir d'éléments précis sur sa
répartition et c'est bien dommage nous
comprenons et déplorons qui les rend
majoritairement à la construction de
place de prison
j'ajoute que devant une moitié épaisse
la question budgétaire ne saurait être
le seul déterminant du vote
revenons sur quelques éléments du texte
vous permettez l'activation à distance
des appareils électroniques à des fins
de géolocalisation pour les crimes et
les délits passifs de plus de 5 ans
d'emprisonnement le Sénat même le Sénat
avait relevé le seuiliste le nombre
d'infractions ainsi visées et tout à
fait considérable sur l'activation des
appareils à des fins d'écoute et de
captation d'image vous nous avez dit
sans que l'on sache d'où viennent ces
chiffres que cela concernerait une
dizaine d'affaires par an monsieur le
ministre mais vous avez refusé tout nous
amendements qui visaient en faire à
faire la transparence sur le nombre réel
de ces activations s'il vous plaît
vous n'avez pas accepté de renforcer le
juge des libertés de la détention le
dotant d'une équipe vous n'avez pas
accepté l'extension du référé pénal
environnemental ce serait pourtant si
utile vous n'avez pas pris au sérieux
nos propositions pour en finir avec les
émissions de l'administration dans la
lutte contre la délinquance
environnementale c'est bien dommage vous
n'avez pas accepté le transfert à la
hatv du pouvoir d'agrément des
associations de lutte contre la
corruption encore un rendez-vous raté
vous n'avez pas accepté le renforcement
du rôle du juge d'application des peines
dans le prononcé des sanctions vous
n'avez pas accepté le mécanisme de
régulation carcéral ça a déjà été dit il
était pourtant tellement attendu en
somme vous n'avez pas cherché à
construire une majorité sur ce texte sur
ces textes avec les écologistes en
revanche vous avez donné à Monsieur
Ciotti 3000 places de prison
supplémentaires qu'il réclamait
vous avez
vous êtes évidemment libre de négocier
avec la droite réactionnaire
c'est votre choix mais ne venez pas
ensuite vous offusquer que nous ne
votions pas votre texte
je veux aussi signaler
que vous avez dans les dernières heures
de discussion sur la loi organique fait
adopter un amendement du rassemblement
national sous amender par le rapporteur
général et oui peut-être est-ce
simplement par confort mais je vous le
dis chers collègues c'est une grave
erreur que de participer encore à
l'entreprise de normalisation accélérée
de l'extrême droite
[Applaudissements]
en tout état de cause sur un texte très
fourni et en dépit des efforts
budgétaires annoncés
et de quelques avancées utiles il ne
nous a pas paru difficile de constater
que la balance pesait du mauvais côté et
croyez bien que pour la justice de notre
pays nous le regrettons vous l'avez
compris les écologistes voteront contre
la loi de programmation je vous remercie
je vous remercie mon cher collègue le
dernier orateur sera d'avis rieman pour
le groupe Ghost démocrate et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
merci de vous installer dans le calme
[Musique]
la présidente
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
qu'est-ce qu'une bonne décision de
justice et comment il parvenir
ce n'est pas mon rôle en tant que
législateur d'apporter une réponse à
cette question ce n'est pas celui du
ministre de la Justice non plus quelle
qualité ses fonctions dans une vie
antérieure c'est l'attitude du juge
appelé à dire le droit parmi les hommes
et les femmes et pour les hommes et les
femmes notre rôle donc c'est d'écouter
ceux qui œuvrent quotidiennement avec
passion et acharnement souvent avec un
certain découragement parfois à faire en
sorte que la machine judiciaire continue
de tourner
ce sont eux qui sont qui ont les
réponses et nous revient d'en faire bon
usage
quel est le rôle de la justice dans la
société quel est son poids face aux
actes répréhensible son importance dans
les esprits ou la défiance prend petit à
petit le dessus
tout n'est pas vilipoder il est
indéniable qu'il y a des moyens qui sont
mis sur la table mais on ne peut pas se
contenter de loi ou certes les milliards
pour la flow mais en aucun sujet de
fonds
[Applaudissements]
non je disais tout n'est pas vilipendé
il est indéniable qu'il y a des moyens
qui sont mis sur la table mais on ne
peut pas se contenter d'une loi ou
certes des milliards pour la flo mais
aucun sujet de fond est véritablement
abordé frontalement pourtant
l'institution judiciaire s'acharne sur
la sonnette d'alarme depuis quelques
temps déjà mais il faut croire que le
double vitrage de votre ministère est de
qualité monsieur le ministre les portes
de votre ministère sont-elles à ce point
imperméable aux deux lance du réel
monsieur le ministre sont-elles à ce
point cadenasser à une vision budgétaire
qui se qui se désintéresse du contenu
les états généraux de la Justice ont
ainsi accouché non pas d'une souris mais
d'un projet de loi hétéroclite un peu
toucher à tout qui ne pose pas l'unique
question qui devrait nous préoccuper la
justice est-elle juste aujourd'hui
ce qui voit des voleurs des violeurs des
assassins à chaque point de rue peuvent
se taper dans le dos et surtout qu'en
gratuit les sur les 3000 places de
présence supplémentaires que le duo de
votre surenchère vous leur avez accordé
bien volontiers
assez chers collègues nous leur
adressons le même message qu'à vous
monsieur le ministre vous faites fausse
route la prison comme seule réponse à la
délinquance est un leurre une réponse
judiciaire de qualité ne se mesure pas à
l'encombrement des prisons mais la
réception des condamnés
pendant que vous achetez les votes de la
droite les magistrats les greffiers et
les agents administratifs doivent gérer
une pénurie qui les use un empilement de
réforme qui n'absorbe plus une justice
sans visa globale
la Fernel nous interroge sur la faculté
qui est aujourd'hui de laisser la
suspension judiciaire de véritablement
ces constituants pouvant indépendant
et sur la politique et sur la politique
de l'autruche est menée de longue date
en France dès lors qu'il s'agit de
restaurer un rapport serein et confiant
entre les citoyens leur police et leur
justice
la défiance grande et elle se
matérialise sous nos yeux dans nos rues
sous nos fenêtres il est l'heure
d'interroger la domination sociale qui
sous-entend les rapports entre nos
institutions et ceux qui ont font le bon
capital social ceux qui n'ont pas la
bonne couleur de peau ceux qui ne
rentrent pas dans le mode dans le modèle
type
ces projets de loi n'en voit rien sinon
ça pèse mort ni par les moyens humains
supplémentaires dont on ne sait rien du
fléchage ni par la dématérialisation
remporte qui grignote encore et un peu
plus le peu du mail en partie qui nous
reste dans nos démarches administratives
et judiciaires
ni par la lotte big motorisation de la
société qui transpose au principe du
présumé innocent celui de la suspicion
légale qui permettra de filmer d'écouter
de géolocaliser des individus avoir
toute condamnation
un peu plus personnel monsieur le
ministre
je tiens à déplorer les lacunes immos de
votre loi de programmation vis-à-vis des
territoires d'outre-mer sur laquelle
vous appliquez un cash misère
la première ministre a annoncé
aujourd'hui les outre-mer était une
chance pour la France l'inverse est-il
vrai
vous auriez pu vous rattraper par le
biais du comité internistériel aux
autres mères qui s'est tenu aujourd'hui
pas une seule fois le mot justice
n'apparaît dans les propositions du
gouvernement la défiance envers l'État
grandit dans nos territoires attention
pour toutes ces raisons
notre groupe est sur deux positions sur
le vote une majorité pour le compte et
l'autre partie pour l'abstention donc
aucune penchera pour l'adoption de ce
texte je vous remercie je vous remercie
mon cher collègue
donc je vais donc mettre au bois en
premier lieu le projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de la Justice pour les années
2023 et 2027 tout le monde a pu regagner
sa place le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votants 544 exprimer 499 majorité 250
pour 388 contre 111 l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté
je vais maintenant mettre voir le projet
de loi organique relative à l'ouverture
la modernisation et la responsabilité du
corps judiciaire le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 545
exprimé 504 majorité 253 pour 439 contre
65 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
monsieur le garde des sceaux vous avez
la parole
merci merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés après le
Sénat c'est l'Assemblée nationale qui
vient à son tour de tourner la page de
la clochardisation de notre justice
abandonnée depuis plus de 30 ans c'est
un moment solonel qui est observé de
près dans tout nos tribunaux et dans
toutes nos prisons soyez-en absolument
convaincus
je vais d'abord remercier bien sûr le
rapporteur général les trois rapporteurs
les responsables de textes le président
Houlier pour l'excellence de leur
travail
et enfin je veux
saluer l'engagement des femmes et des
hommes magistrats greffiers à Jean
administratif
avocat tous ceux qui font fonctionner la
justice au quotidien ils attendaient ce
texte
ils attendaient que les États généraux
se concrétisent c'est grâce à vous
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
aujourd'hui chose faite je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la séance est sus
[Applaudissements]